so why did this become so political
because it seems like we started off
this conversation
and most of these conversations start
off with like an actual medical
conversation about a condition
and how best to treat the condition and
there's a debate between watchful
waiting
and as you say sort of affirmation
watchful waiting in most of these areas
was considered sort of the traditional
way to go about these things
and there's been an attempt even
politically there to treat watchful
waiting as quote-unquote conversion
therapy that if you
if you go to a therapist and the
therapist does not immediately recommend
a course of treatment
then this is now considered conversion
therapy in some places like california
um you know how did this become so
political when it really should be about
how do we best treat people who have an
obvious medical condition
that's right i think it it happened in a
series of lies that we allowed to
to you know that we were too polite to
contradict
like we started with you know okay you
know
you know um this is a civil rights issue
to allow them to have that medication
well you know giving someone access to a
medication that could harm them
isn't really a civil rights issue when
it means suspending all medical judgment
hold on i mean we should still subject
it to the same scrutiny
because we don't want transgender people
to come to great harm
i mean a lot of these medicals is
enormously dangerous
we don't know the long-term you know
side effects and implications of giving
a woman 10 to 40 times
her normal testosterone levels for
decades and that's what you would have
to do with she becomes a lifetime
patient so we allow these you know
little lies to be told
it's okay she really is a man she's she
is a man let's change her birth
certificates
and then we ended up in a place where we
could no longer object
and that is you know i think a lot of
the mission here is this idea that
yeah i've said publicly obviously that
when i'm discussing
somebody who is trans i use their
biological pronouns i say a man who
believes he's a woman
if we're talking about a trans woman uh
or i say a trans woman
but i won't say that somebody is a woman
when they are not in fact a biological
woman now if i'm
in the middle of a conversation with
somebody who is trans i'll call them
whatever they want because you don't
want to be impolite when you're
in the middle of dinner with with
somebody um but there is this this
broader conversation that's now
happening on social media for example
where if you point out that caitlyn
jenner is in fact a biological man
should you be banned from social media
i mean it's reached the stage where
full-scale first amendment conversations
uh are being shut down in the name of uh
in the name of niceness
that's right and you know i talked to a
lot of older
you know what they used to call what
transsexuals um
not now referred to as transgender but
they they never lie about the fact that
they used to you know
they they grew up as as boys even though
they now present as women
um they never demand that everyone
pretend they were always a woman
um this is a very new thing and it's
it's part of the intolerance and
extremism of this very
young woke generation of young you know
the the millennials in the gen z
who are so coercive who are so
intolerant who are so
liberal and who demand you recite after
them
and it really is more part of that than
it is part of the
you know traditional experience of
transgender adults who are
lovely sober rational and and they don't
lie
i mean i i've interviewed a lot of them
and they're wonderful people and these
activists don't represent them at all
did you know that every like on this
video creates one additional
leftist here gleaming in the sunshine
don't ask me why that's called science
to take advantage of this amazing
opportunity
hit the like button